I have not heard this but Troy told me
that you know a superhuman represents
the Insane Clown Posse oh thank you for
attending the show today you know how he
always brings up the Insane Clown Posse
Juggalos and juggle let's that his fans
of the Insane Clown Posse that's who the
Juggalos and juggle let's our Troy came
to me and said that that superhuman
collaborated with the Insane Clown Posse
is that true Troy that is correct
there's a couple things going on here
okay okay one I wanted to write a song
or produce a song I should say I didn't
like this rich just blew his nose in the
microphone cover you know you look off
button yeah or like has a cough button
by the way you didn't mean you backed up
it's very slightly but you were in exact
direction of the microphone so he's very
very very audible superhuman I see it
superhuman you bring it back to you okay
good all right all right cool then all
right so now that we got that other way
Troy as you were saying yeah so wanted
to just put something together have them
collaborate on a song together and then
it this to me is an olive branch to
superhuman like superhuman we put
together a song you love ICP your
Juggalo mm-hmm there's a studio filled
with Juggalos here I mean nothing that's
actually a prerequisite when we hired
Mike Montone recently yeah one of the
guy was eating on the interview and I
said would you consider yourself a
Juggalo and he went yeah of course I got
mad clown love I said okay just a
superhuman we're all family family
family yeah and yeah he should come on
the show and you know we should do them
we are a service are you are you juggle
oh yeah of course I'm chuckle oh you're
not a jug a hoe no there you go are you
down with the clown I'm done the ground
okay all right okay the clown from okay
you [ __ ] dark baked scum man this
[ __ ] I know that's no problem so I'll
give this song to Rob he'll put it into
a YouTube video yeah and then we'll
tweet it
to him that's fair yeah I like that good
so Trey you want to hear it let's hear
we hear the song that Troy put together
I would love to okay
Juggalos they're gentle eyes don't try
this at home I hope
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a couple of things number one I liked
that we created a melody out of the
crashing the south
what was that crashing exactly do you
remember what the stunt was the light
bulbs really had the best impact I also
ironically I think I enjoyed the
superhuman parts more than the Insane
Clown Posse parts of that song he's that
they're beat that song it was just a
beat at was actually a twisted beat that
I'd kind of jacked up a little bit I say
balls and then I found a couple ICP
acapellas I see I chopped up what they
said to kind of make they sort of were
rapping about somebody so I made him rap
about Superman I see I see
very good well there you go insane clown
posse featuring superhuman right one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app